with Larry David you would probably
throw that guy so much [ __ ] money how
much do you think he got paid I'm
thinking
he threw out a ridiculous number and
they said fine because Larry's so much
so much money Larry's got what half a
bill a billion yeah
you got Seinfeld money plus curve money
to motivate him it's almost not even
money he only seems to do exactly what
he wants to do in that yeah let him play
himself and he got to roast it there's
no one's getting 30 on that he got paid
right he got paid they were like hey you
want to be in a Super Bowl commercial I
think there's a lot of people who would
have just been like sure yeah to know
that it's still being in a Super Bowl
commercial Larry don't get mine he
definitely asked for I guess what I'm
just trying to say is like these are
people that can't be bothered like Tom
Larry can't be bothered you could be
more bothered I could be very bothered
yeah I could be very very bothered you
texted me and I came
[Music]